the countless thousands of haitians
pouring across our southern border have
divided americans conservatives argue
that nations need borders and we cannot
tolerate a flood of foreign nationals
violating our most basic laws
leftists argue that we owe it to the
people of haiti to take them in as many
as want to come should be allowed to
come and border patrol should not lift a
finger to stop them
up until now president joe biden has
remained quiet on the issue but at long
last we finally have video of president
biden's view of haitians and their
island nation as it pertains to the
national interest of the united states
if haiti a god-awful thing to say if
haiti just quietly sunk into the
caribbean or rose up 300 feet
it wouldn't matter a whole lot in terms
of the world well said mr president now
in fairness joe biden said that back in
1994 back when
people still had at least the semblance
of a sliver of common sense today the
biden administration is attacking its
own border patrol agents for in any way
attempting to enforce the law
so is it any surprise that americans fed
up with the lawlessness are beginning to
take the law into their own hands i'm
michael knowles it's the michael knoll
show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from thor darshan who
says if the democrats are able to enact
their global vision we will have an
embassy in every country that flies
hunter biden's paintings just below the
pride flag that
comment is actually even more profound
than the commenter probably knew because
yes it's true the symbol of american
imperial hegemony these days is just the
gay pride flag and we're gonna raise it
in kandahar and we're gonna raise it all
over the place but this is not because
of some
coherent moral
philosophy that is being pushed by the
liberal imperialists it's mostly just a
grift what the left is doing is
appealing to our most base passions and
our appetites
consumerism sex whatever they're
appealing to all of that
to entrench their power for this
oligarchy that is basically just
enriching themselves by selling
hunter biden stupid finger painting for
half a million dollars by by enriching
themselves at the expense of our
political order it drives me nuts when
people disrespect good americans that
way which is why
i'm so supportive
of good ranchers did you know that over
80 percent of the grass-fed beef sold in
the united states is imported from
overseas
well
it might be local in guatemala or
something but it's not local here which
is why the good ranchers have gone out
to american ranches to bring american
meat to the american consumer all at an
incredible
price head on over to
goodranchers.com you get better than
organic chicken you'll get american
craft beef they have t-bones fillets
strips gourmet burgers and more
at half the price of online competitors
you will get the steakhouse quality you
deserve the price every family can
afford
i really love good ranchers they got all
the cuts you want t-bones fillets strips
for me this is going to sound kind of
basic i love those burgers their gourmet
burgers are magnificent go to
goodranchers.com knowles right now save
20 bucks or better yet subscribe and
save on each box of mouth-watering
american meats that will show up on
schedule right to your door that is
twenty dollars off and free express
shipping if you go to goodranchers.com
knowlescannonwles or use codenoles at
checkout 20 bucks off and free shipping
at goodranchers.com
knowles the
crisis at the border
is supposed to play well for democrats
that was the idea you're going to open
it up the poor oppressed insert whatever
foreign nation in the world is pouring
over our border we've got to let them
across we're the cause of all their
problems and we
we're such a terrible country and that's
why we've got to let them into
our terrible country and we owe it to
them and we
we're the only nation on earth that
shouldn't have borders so knock all of
them down and i think the american
people are sick of that i think it that
doesn't work and so the main way that
the left tries to
gin up this kind of division is through
race hustling
and in this case because it's a bunch of
haitians pouring over the border how did
they get here i don't know i you know i
know that the biden administration
gensake is saying that they don't plan
to stay very long and yeah they the
haitians just made it all the way over
to mexico and then they're running
across the border just for a long
weekend away or something but but
because they're haitian now you have an
added element of of black lives matter
right these are black people and so
obviously the only reason to keep
foreigners out of our country is because
they're black so al sharpton
the
the race hustler
par excellence left in our country flies
down to the border and he and he starts
to give one of his stupid race hustling
lectures
but he's not as well received down there
in texas as he often is actually he gets
heckled while giving his extremely dumb
remarks
nobody wants to hear
wow you know i didn't expect to hear
such common sense remarks in that speech
i wasn't hearing it from al sharpton i
was hearing it from the hecklers in
texas and it's true al sharpton is a
disgrace i mean he's been a hustler and
a pimp his entire career he launched his
career on a rape hoax the tuwana brawley
hoax virtually everything else the guy's
been involved in is a hoax and it's just
a shakedown so that anytime he can claim
some sort of
racial offense he can he can shake down
corporations and local communities and
enrich himself
frankly i i had a greater deal of
respect for al sharpton back when he was
a big fat guy wearing those expensive
pinstriped suits just walking around new
york shaking people down like the
mobster that he is now that he looks
like a shriveled up little raisin and
he's wearing his kind of more you know
put together a higher higher class more
muted uh you know little vest and his
little his little nice shirt i don't
know it doesn't doesn't play as well to
me it's sort of sad and i don't think
the american people are really buying it
either but the problem is
the problem is
the libs still have all the power
and we don't really have the power so
yes people are shouting down al sharpton
if you look at public opinion polls the
immigration crisis at the border is a
disaster for joe biden's poll numbers
but they're not going to change course
because they have all of the
institutional power so jensaki was asked
about about this she was asked about
that complete non-traversing that
fiction
that border patrol agents were using
whips against haitian
illegal aliens who were pouring across
they weren't using whips they were
holding rains so they could ride their
horses and based on this lie
jensaki is now saying yeah we're gonna
punish the border patrol they're no
longer allowed to use horses
what he has asked all of us to convey
clearly to people who are understandably
have questions are passionate are
concerned as we are about the images
that we have seen is one we feel those
images are horrible and horrific there
is an investigation the president
certainly supports overseen by this the
department of homeland security which he
has conveyed will will happen quickly i
can also convey to you that the
secretary also conveyed to civil rights
leaders earlier this morning that we
would no longer be using horses in del
rio so that is something a policy change
that has been made in response but
separately all related it's also
important for people to understand what
our process and our immigration process
is and what the steps are that are taken
now i agree with jenn saki here the
images we saw were horrible and horrific
because a lot of the criminal migrants
were getting through that was what was
horrible what was horrible is not that
law enforcement was attempting to
enforce the law what was horrible is
that they weren't doing it
very effectively because the politicians
notably people in the white house were
tying their arms behind their backs
now the white house is saying no more
can border patrol use horseback
in in this area what are they going to
use
they can't in certain areas they can't
take a humvee they can't take uh uh
crown victoria they can't they can't
take these cars into these they can't
even take four by fours into these into
these areas
so what are they gonna they they can
ride on horseback but now they're not
allowed to ride on horseback
oh no what a what a mistake what
incompetence some people say from the
biden administration please please
don't give me that
it's amazing to me that some republicans
still say this is incompetence
it's not incompetence
it's the point
but if if you get rid of horseback then
they won't be able to enforce the law
right
that's the point they don't want to
enforce the law
the law is good for the american people
it's good for the national integrity of
our country
but it's bad for democrats because then
democrats can't flood the country with
future voters statistically illegal
aliens are overwhelmingly likely to
identify with democrats with the
destruction of voter integrity measures
they can probably vote in the next
election but even if they can't because
of our
new or our understanding of birthright
citizenship the idea that if you are a
foreigner who comes here and has a kid
you just ought the kid automatically
gets citizenship then they're certainly
going to get a lot of voters down the
line and with the mass amnesty that the
democrats keep trying to cram through
they'll probably get it much sooner than
that
so they've got the power and they're
going to do it that's just the way it
goes
i wonder when aoc is going to go down to
the border and start crying like she did
under trump you remember that
the kids in cages she wasn't actually
crying in front of kids in cages she was
crying in front of a parking lot and
that white suit and she pretended to cry
and it was not
not exactly a marlon brando kind of
performance but it got the message
across
aoc has not done that she's she's not
going to do that because now it's the
biden administration
which is enforcing this sort of stuff so
it's not good pr
she has been crying though
she's crying because
she was not able to stop the congress
from giving a billion dollars to israel
to fund their their uh missile defense
system
and she so she just starts crying you
can see video of her on on the floor of
the house just sobbing oh no the jews
are going to be able to protect
themselves no
this is defensive missiles by the way
it's not offensive missiles it's the
iron dome system no those jews are going
to have
defensive weaponry no now the muslim
terrorists in the palestinian
territories can't shoot at them no first
of all hysterical people should not be
in public life okay if this woman can't
keep her emotions together
while she's on the floor of the congress
she shouldn't be there she's she's a too
frivolous a person to be there it's not
god i understand she might get reelected
but it's bad it's not good for public
life uh
but but it's also worth pointing out why
she is crying
she's crying because we're paying for
israel's defensive missiles
a lot of conservatives don't like
foreign aid some conservatives don't
like israel i'm not making a point on
either of those things right now i am
asking you to consider why
she is crying
she's crying that israel can defend
itself because she and her ilk view
israel as an extension and really a
creation of western imperialism
they view the modern nation state of
israel as an expansion of western
imperialism in the middle east as a
symbol of western civilization which
they hate which they want to subvert
that's why they want to get rid of
israel so regardless of your views on
modern nation state of israel regardless
of your views on us giving foreign aid
willy-nilly all over the place don't
don't get confused here
the reason that that aoc hates israel is
because she hates you because she hates
this civilization that
we on the right are attempting to defend
you know when you want
to to really defend the the health not
just of our civilization but of yourself
i would strongly recommend you check out
superbeats i've got a new way to start
your day super beets heart chews they
are a tasty treat to give you the energy
that you need that are also good for you
no more afternoon coffees energy drinks
or candy for a quick pick-me-up add two
delicious plant-based super beets heart
shoes to your morning routine and
promote heart-healthy energy for your
day without a caffeine crash the grape
seed extract used in super beets heart
shoes has been clinically shown to be
two times as effective at supporting
normal blood pressure as a healthy
lifestyle alone
really would recommend this especially
you know if you're
working long hours you find yourself
tired you got a sweet cute little babies
screaming and keeping you up all night i
don't know i'm just thinking
hypothetically i would strongly
recommend super beets heart chews for
heart healthy energy you should to join
over 1 million customers get free
shipping and returns a 90-day money-back
guarantee and right now you can get a
free 30-day supply with your first
purchase at
superbeats.com
knowles the defining feature of
the left
of the libs the kind of liberal rule
more broadly is that it wants to tear
down
that which distinguishes the west
heihei ho ho western civ has got to go
as jesse jackson said well he marched
through stanford university
tear down the statues tear down our
traditions tear down our system of law
tear down our borders tear down the
things that distinguish us and set us
apart from the rest of the world
you're seeing this right now
in a specific way in michigan the
attorney general of michigan
dana nessel
is
very upset about the pro-life law in
texas and there's actually some really
good news on that from around the
country which we'll get to in a bit
but
but she says quote
adultery is a felony in michigan
the prohibition was passed the same year
as michigan's abortion ban
do those who support the texas abortion
law also support granting standing to
private citizens to sue adulterers when
they violate the law
what say you michigan legislators huh
got you there uh what what do you think
that adultery should be a crime too
yeah sure why not
why not what's i mean i don't think that
adultery i don't think that cheating on
your wife and killing a baby are on the
same level
i think one of those things is graver
than the other
but yeah they're both pretty bad and i
don't think that we should really
encourage either of them and yeah they
both were illegal for a very long time
for most of our civilization's history
so yeah why why wouldn't we do that
wait what you think that yeah we do
think that this this is just like when
the libs when the texas abortion law
came out and the libs said huh well i'll
tell you what rachel maddow made this
point my doppelganger i made this point
of running msnbc
she said well you know if we're not
going to allow legal abortion then we
should hold the men responsible for
staying with their children
uh okay
yeah sounds great oh you we should make
no fault divorce
harder yeah i agree that's a good idea
you're coming around rachel you're
coming around libs you're coming around
michigan
attorney general of course we should
at its most basic level
all polities all political communities
attempt to pursue good and avoid evil
that's what we do and how do we do that
well by protecting certain liberties
here by protecting the integrity of
these institutions or by keeping some
power separate in this government the
local government versus the but
what we are trying to do it's just the
most simple level
do good
avoid evil adultery is bad
uh we shouldn't have it
and so yeah i guess we should discourage
it that's pretty basic stuff
politicians are really misunderstanding
this this political moment
a woman on the new york city subway
showed the political moment there i just
saw these when i was in new york a ton
of really gross dating app ads where
it's people like licking each other's
mouths and simulating sex and in some
cases like they got people propped up on
countertops and little things so this
woman
sees them and just starts ripping them
to be looking at this is down okay is
that okay for kids to be looking at this
gross stuff on the subway propaganda
yeah it is probably normalizing
normalizing the next generation you're
normalizing all these kind of sick weird
gender styles
like no one sees this you're
i also love that just very few people
are wearing masks on the subway
like some people are but a lot of people
right now when i was there
you look up it's like oh gross it's like
someone with their finger going through
an apple obviously simulating some gross
stuff
also some gardening imagery there
yeah it's gross people with their
tongues in each other's mouths so
the the debate is
what is freedom
living in a society where anyone can put
any kind of gross obscene weird porn
stuff all over the subways for everyone
to see including little kids or is the
free community the one that can band
together and say no we don't want this
crap on our subways and we don't want to
allow
sick degenerate corporations to
enrich themselves by rousing up all our
bases passions and having porn
everywhere
which is
what is the freedom you can kind of see
an argument either way right
so i think the people who are missing
the moment
the libs
and
and
to some degree the libertarians the ones
who say like you know my the greatest
freedom is to just look at porn
everywhere right though i think those
guys are misunderstanding where people
are i think most of the american people
especially younger americans are with
that woman saying we don't want this
filth we don't want this degeneracy
everywhere okay it's not good for us
personally it's not good for our
political community it's not good for
our country
you know this
this gets to
a debate that we had on on the last
episode of backstage okay i'll give you
the perfect example of it
nancy pelosi nancy pelosi was just asked
as a catholic allegedly to defend her
views on abortion catholic church says
you can't can't have abortions you can't
encourage abortions if you're a
politician you can't go along with
abortion she says well i have a
difference of opinion with the catholic
church on that and she makes
a ridiculous moral
argument for why that's the case
yeah i'm catholic
i come from a pro-life family
not
active in that regard uh different in
their view of a woman's right to choose
than i am
in my
right to choose i have five children in
six years in one week
and i keep saying to people who say
things like that when you have five
children in six days
six years in one day we can talk about
what businesses of any of us tell anyone
else to do for us it was a complete and
total blessing which we enjoy
every day of our lives but it's none of
our business how other people choose the
size and timing of their families
my uh the
my
the archbishop of the city of uh that
area of san francisco and i have a
disagreement about who should decide
this
i believe that god has given us
a free will
to honor our responsibilities
we need to have legal abortion because
god gives us free will and so it's
actually wrong it's unchristian
to prevent people from exercising their
free will yes i think abortion's wrong
for me i would never kill any of my
precious children but poor people and
disproportionately black people yes they
should be able to kill their kids we
have a lot of them don't we yeah all
those little poor people running around
yes
no look i would never do it
why would you never do it nancy
because it's wrong
but you think that it should be legal to
do wrong things god gives us free will
and it is therefore unchristian
to outlaw things that are manifestly
wrong even killing babies
this gets to a debate that we had on the
last episode of backstage actually there
were the kind of the more
traditional concert it was me
matt
to some degree i think drew were saying
no you should you should not be able to
do that kind of stuff and then ben and
jeremy were making the point
that you should you should have the
right to sin now i think we would all
agree abortion should not be legal okay
so we would all agree on that point
but and i think we would all agree but
nancy pelosi might not agree
that a theft should be illegal murder
should be illegal
hey nancy do you god gave you free will
so should you have the ability to go
steal something it's wrong you shouldn't
do it but should you have the you have
the right to do it you have the freedom
to do it you just need to choose not to
do it right no nobody thinks that well
god gave me free will so murder should
be legal i don't think we should commit
murders but murder should be illegal uh
no everyone should choose for themselves
if they want to commit murder if they
want to commit theft no i don't think so
but then i think where the divide might
be is you say okay look you don't have
the right to commit a sin that harms
someone else but you do have the right
to commit a sin that harms yourself now
first of all there is no sin that
doesn't harm anyone else it has we all
live in a society it has effects on the
world but
the the most private sorts of sins let's
say um
drugs or something
in american history i mean it's
completely
anti-historical ahistorical to say that
you know it's deeply american to have
the right to harm yourself to commit a
private personal sin we've had laws
against drugs we've had laws against
certain sexual behaviors we've had all
sorts of laws that prevent you from
doing that but now the more libertarian
argument is you should be allowed to
overdose on drugs if you want you should
be allowed to do whatever you want with
your body as long as it doesn't scare
the horses in the street and the
conservative argument is no you you
shouldn't
what it comes down to
is this this question
do you have the right to sin it would
seem to me that error has no rights
okay you you don't you don't have the
right to commit theft you don't have the
right to commit murder you don't have
the right to kill your baby you don't at
least for now have the right to do a
bunch of illegal drugs you don't have
the right to
mutilate yourself you don't have the
right to kill yourself you you actually
don't have those rights there are
just certain moral realities that you
cannot transgress okay but that that's
the debate of our time right now that's
the big debate going on this this notion
of radical individual autonomy i can do
whatever i want just don't tell me no or
this notion of do we want a good society
and i think the way it plays out is you
got
porn all over the subways or you've got
something of the society that we seem to
have lost a more ordered society where
things make a little more sense which
society do you want to live in
you know i want to protect not just my
life not just my society but also
i want to protect
my data and my identity that's why i
would recommend checking out lifelock do
you do anything on the internet well if
so your information is at risk okay
payment apps like venmo cash app and
others may make payments easy
but also you might want to adjust your
privacy settings to prevent them from
sharing your personal information
there's a new report just found that
payment apps share user data with third
parties such as banks and fraud
monitoring services some even share it
with marketing firms very important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are affecting our lives every
single day just about every minute of
the day we put our information at risk
on the internet in an instant a cyber
criminal could harm what's yours your
finances your credit your reputation
good thing there's lifelock lifelock
helps detect a wide range of identity
threats like your social security number
for sale on the dark web you have access
to a dedicated restoration specialist if
you become a victim and no one can
monitor all identity theft
or all transactions at all businesses
but you can keep what's yours with
lifelock by norton join now save up to
25 off your first year at lifelock.com
knowles that's lifelock dot com slash
knowles canada wlas for 25
off we got some really good news right
now
out of
florida
and i was i was hoping that this would
happen but now it seems to have happened
so we got the texas pro-life law i asked
some of the people who were involved in
drafting the texas pro-life law will
this texas pro-life law
be replicated in other states or is it
just peculiar to texas
and
the the legislator who came who drafted
the law and came up with it said it can
be replicated in other states you need
some tweaks but
it could work
well that's already happening uh florida
republican state lawmaker
on wednesday introduced a bill that is
modeled after a strict texas law
prohibiting abortions after six weeks
that that wonderful pro-life law it's
called house bill 167 it's uh by
representative webster barnaby and it
does the same thing you can you can sue
people if they're committing abortions
if they're involved in abortions this is
really great stuff
we need to go on the offense
and it ties in with this broader theme
we've been talking about where is the
future
of the right and where is the future of
the country for a great many decades
the right was could only agree on one
thing in particular
maximize individual autonomy choice do
whatever you want just don't make me pay
for it
i think we have seen that that is
insufficient
i think that having lost
our institutions having lost
the definition of marriage having lost
the nature of sex itself having lost
education having lost
every having lost everything
other than occasional tax cuts i think
we've realized that vision is
insufficient
because all societies need to
do something
all societies need to value certain
things and oppose other things and if
we're not going to offer a vision of
what we think the good is then the only
vision you're going to have is from the
left and then the left because nature
abhors a vacuum is going to take over
so i think this is good stuff i think
all the other states with republican
governors and legislatures need to go on
the offense need to start passing this
stuff okay
move the culture in that direction
that's going to
be difficult for some squishy
republicans who who even some squishy
republicans even on the issue of
abortion say well i don't know can't we
ugh can't we just avoid the culture wars
let's just talk about
you know bumping up gdp a little bit can
we let's just talk about tweaking the
health care system no let's talk about
justice let's talk about virtue let's
talk about the kind of society we want
to live in
do you want to live in an angry crazy
senseless society that's just saturated
in filth or do you want to live in a
society that's not perfect it's never
going to be perfect this is a fallen
world but it's just a little bit nicer
where things are a little more stable
where the family is a little more stable
where our local communities are a little
more stable where you you can take your
kid onto the subway without seeing
creepy you know gender-bending porn
which which one do you want to live in i
think we would all agree
the latter
but one of the big hold-ups to getting
back to a normal society is that the
liberal establishment has just taken a
ton
of power
they've taken a ton of power away from
you and they've done it through our
kovid regime
as long as the emergency of kovid lasts
then these rulers can rule however they
wish
with with whatever whims and caprices
they like
15 days to slow the spread is now
well over a year and a half
now
this is probably going to be censored
but i'll say it anyway the creator of
the astrazeneca vaccine a very very
important
scientist
professor dame
sarah gilbert has just come out and said
that eventually kovid will just be a
cold it'll just be a common cold some of
us have been saying that for most people
it it is a cold already for some people
it's very serious but for for most
people it just it's just kind of like a
cold it's like a bad cold but it's fine
she says eventually it's just going to
be a cold for everyone this is just this
is what happened she says quote
we already live with four different
human coronaviruses that we don't really
ever think about very much and
eventually soros covet ii covid19 the
woofloo will become one of those it's
just a question of how long it's going
to take to get there and what measures
we're going to have to take to manage it
in the meantime
why does this happen because quote
viruses become less virulent as they
circulate more easily and there's no
reason to think that we will have a more
virulent version of covid19 we tend to
see slow genetic drift of the virus and
there will be gradual immunity
developing in the population as there is
to all the other seasonal coronaviruses
good news
but how long is this going to go on for
one of the vaccine manufacturers i
forget which one i think was moderna but
who knows it's one of them says you know
i think kovit i think these difficult
covet measures are going to go on for
another year
oh do you do you you people who are most
profiting from coronavirus you think
it's going to other than amazon is
profiting the most you think it's going
to go on another year i bet in a year
you're going to hear oh it's going to go
on another year another two years
another three years
this stuff
is not going away
until
we tell it to until we make it go away
you know lyanna wen who's the former
president of planned parenthood she now
goes on cnn all of the time and she she
talks about her health advice she says
we are
nowhere near
allowing kids to lose masks in schools
i agree that masks are a very powerful
layer of protection but it's one layer
and if we have so many other layers that
are present masking may be one that
could go away but i would say that let's
say a school where it is or a particular
class everybody is vaccinated in that
class and also the level of community
transmission is declining i could
imagine that situation being where we
remove masks because we have all these
other layers or if we have rapid testing
imagine if every child and teacher were
tested every morning and also they're
vaccinated you can imagine that
situation even if there's high levels of
community spread that maybe you can
remove masks at that time but we are
nowhere near that yet and i think what
we really need to do is get the vaccines
authorized for children as soon as
that's possible and also really ramp up
testing because that is a powerful tool
that we're just not using across the
country as we should be we're just we're
nowhere near where we need to be to let
little kids take off the masks even
though kids statistically face virtually
no risk very very very very little risk
from the coronavirus and then the people
who are vaccinated
we are also told face very very little
risk from serious disease so you can't
worry that the kids are just going to
spread it to the vulnerable people
because the vulnerable people already
have the vaccine unless the libs are
lying about something somewhere down the
line
nowhere near it but you could see a
world you can see a light at the end of
the tunnel just allow us to keep power
for a little while longer lyanna nguyen
is a curious figure because she's
talking about the
the health of children and she of course
is best known for running an
organization that kills hundreds of
thousands of children a year that that
their job is to kill little babies
but liana wen was also pushed out
because she wanted to de-emphasize
abortion at planned parenthood she
wanted to at least have a little cover
at planned parenthood to say no that's
not all that we do here and so they
booted they said no that is that is all
that we do you're you're out liana win
so she's a a confounding figure i think
she's a
good
representative of the quote-unquote
moderate liberal view which isn't very
moderate at all it's it's quite extreme
to the left but i think that if you look
at what leanna when is saying here that
is the voice of the establishment
yes
there's a world in which we can almost
go back to normal even though we're
still going to have the power to do
whatever we want
but we're nowhere near that yet
oh we're not just a little bit longer
just a little bit longer how much longer
are we supposed to wait before we all
start taking down signs in the subway
like that lady in new york
you know systemic corruption infects our
institutions
and all of the elites blame you we've
been talking about that on this show
well drew
just gonna talk about that today on the
andrew clayman show so go check that out
also subscribe and listen to morning
wire on apple spotify wherever you
listen to podcasts and leave a five star
review if you like what you hear we'll
be right back with the mailbag
welcome back to the show my favorite uh
um not my favorite comment these are my
favorite time of the week this is the
mailbag first question from daniel
michael i started dating my girlfriend a
couple weeks ago however i have had
strong feelings for another girl who has
expressed that she wants to be with me
but doesn't want to be in a relationship
uh-huh the situation is rather difficult
as we see each other very often and the
chemistry is still there i want to be
with this girl but i would rather be in
a serious relationship rather than just
something meaningless is there anything
i can do
so you're telling me so you got this
girlfriend who seems nice enough and
then there's this other girl
who you've got the hots for and she's
got the hots for you but she doesn't
want to be in a relationship with you
because she's got the hots for other
guys too and so what you want to do is
dump your good girlfriend to go hang out
with this trumpet so you can have casual
sex
on those happy occasions when she's not
having casual sex with other guys that's
what you're saying
oh to be young to be young and stupid
gosh it's been a while but i
i know i know
i know guys think this way young people
think this way
but i hope that my describing the
situation to you am i just
repeating back to you what you have told
me will let you see clearly you should
definitely not be with this trumpet
that's not a good idea
you maybe should not even be in a
relationship with your girlfriend
because it sounds like you you're not
ready for a relationship you know you're
just kind of settling for her or
something like that
i i would recommend
trying to
work on a little bit of chastity easier
said than done it's easier for an old
man like me an old married man with a
kid to talk about this than a
young person like you uh but
i i think that
it's it's quite clear that what would be
better for you
and for society is for you to be in the
more kind of steady relationship uh with
the girl who's not going to lead you
astray
so either do that and take that
seriously and make a decision and work
on that
or don't break up with both girls you
know don't just take this your
girlfriend as a consolation prize if
you're really not into her and uh
you know wait wait until someone that
you you do like comes along
but i would not uh
good grief it's amazing i mean i know
that men think this way i was i was
young once so i i do know but it reminds
me of this joke that drew clavin talks
about the joke about the guy who hasn't
who wants [ __ ] walks into a bar with an
orange for a head and the the short
version of it is the bartender says all
right you're going to tell me how you
got an orange for a head he says well
you know i walked on the beach i found a
magic lamp and a genie came out i
wouldn't believe it he said i'll give
you three wishes i said okay well if
you're really a genie i want you to give
me a million dollars i go home oh my
gosh publishers clearinghouse shows up a
million dollar check i go okay you know
i want to i want to sleep with every
playboy playmate you know of the last
year i knock knock knock on the door oh
my gosh all these women show up wow
that's amazing
says okay well what happened then he
goes well you know i had one more wish
and uh here's the part that's uh
well
i asked to have an orange for a head
and not some people really don't get
that joke but it's a joke about the
perversity of mankind we just we are
self sabotaging creatures and that's
what you're doing buddy you're
sabotaging yourself so don't do that
from seth
dear michael i've been watching your
show almost daily since i discovered it
two years ago thank you and have
purchased speechless controlling words
controlling minds thank you oh man
you're a gentleman and a scholar i agree
with you on probably everything but the
death penalty do we sinners have the
authority to condemn somebody to death
does justice not belong to god and as it
does if the death penalty also isn't as
effective as a deterrent in life in
prison then what argument is left to
prefer the death penalty over mercy and
giving ourselves every bit of time to
try to convert these criminals hope to
hear from you soon love you sincerely
the ghost of saddam hussein
okay well first of all your hypothetical
there is a big if if it's not a
deterrent i actually think the death
penalty is a deterrent when it is
implemented right now we don't really
implement it all that much so when
studies come out and say it's not really
deterring crime well right we don't
really implement it uh it seems like a
decent deterrent to me but deterrence is
not the primary purpose
now you mentioned shouldn't we have time
to convert the
the
people who are on death row the people
who otherwise we would execute
well
you're getting to rehabilitation now
which is another reason it's another
argument for the criminal justice system
but it seems to me
that hanging concentrates the mind it
seems to me you might have a far better
chance of converting someone if he knows
that he's on the brink of death that
he's facing the gallows
so the rehabilitation aspect i think is
already there and then you say well
what's the point
the point is neither deterrence nor
rehabilitation primarily but justice
the point is justice do i think that we
lowly sinners have the right to kill
people no
but i think that
or at self-defense i suppose we do which
is one argument for the death penalty
but rather than me or you
i think that the civil authority has the
right
for capital punishment actually the
bible says so too saint paul makes it
very clear
the old testament makes it very clear
he who sheds the blood of man by man
shall his blood be shed
i think that history makes it very clear
i i think that uh
if we have the right to throw people in
prison for
70 years or 50 years
why would we not have the right to kill
them
i don't i mean we through the civil
authority i don't i don't really
understand that
it seems to me you're taking
justice to one of these to this extreme
of
uh we should never pass any judgments
whatsoever we need to have justice in
society or i don't think there's
anything christian or biblical or right
or just about letting the cruel rape the
earth now it needs to be it can't be
revenge it can't be just vigilantism all
over the place but we have a criminal
justice system in place it's relatively
effective so it seems fine to me
one of the one of the arguments you'll
hear is catholics cannot support the
death penalty first of all catholics
many catholics support the death penalty
as pope benedict says very well there
can be a legitimate disagreement about
the implementation of the death penalty
among catholics and in fact many popes
have
carried out the death penalty and
blessed pius ix carried out a lot of
executions in the papal states so
that just seems to me very modern a kind
of modern
liberal or libertarian argument that
does not hold a lot of historical water
from michael mastronos i would like to
know your opinion on the idea of putting
a fleece before the lord referencing the
story of gideon in the bible
i have a family member who often urges
me to do this as a way to find direction
from god however it makes me feel as
though i'm seeking god to be my personal
genie rather than living by faith and
wisdom of the holy spirit the only time
i feel biblically confident in testing
god would be in finances specifically
with tithing okay
putting a fleece before the lord just
feels icky to me what are your thoughts
on this ps my wife is jealous of how
much i admire you
let's be friends sincerely a fellow
michael oh thank you so for those who
don't know putting a fleece before the
lord is
basically asking for a sign you know
lord i have to make this difficult
decision so you know tell me what i
should do
people pray for this sort of thing it's
very nice
to to get these sorts of things but
don't forget that it is an evil
generation that seeks for signs and
wonders
my priest father george rutler in new
york very wise man
points this out he says it's an evil
generation that seeks for signs and
wonders but it is a stupid generation
that ignores signs and wonders very
often you will
get some kind of
you will see some kind of symbol in the
world
uh i myself have had this happen you
know i was an atheist for a very long
time then i started to revert
and i became intellectually convinced
and then during the period where i
really
my faith solidified
i was it was a really wild time i mean i
was having what you would call religious
experience that was happening quite a
lot and there were these sort of
numinous events and symbols and maybe
coincidences you would say or but i
really don't think there are many
coincidences so
what does that mean what does it mean
when you get a sign from the lord
i try not to interpret these things and
divine their special meaning and you
know act like a sorcerer or a magician
to me the meaning of the sign is that
the lord is there there is an order to
the universe there is such a thing as
providence and the good lord has endowed
you with moral reasoning judgment
conscience and i think you should you
should rely on that and not just
you know try to read the tea leaves i
think i i agree with your feeling that
that generally is icky to put the lord
your god to the test from shaffer hi
michael my wife and i are about to have
our first baby and we're looking to
confirm that our babies godparents need
to be of the catholic faith in good
standing and confirmed is this accurate
i've i've done some research and it
seems that this is the case but we heard
from others that it's not necessary uh
we will ask our priest on sunday but if
you could address this before then i
don't want to leave him speechless
that we don't know the answer to this
love the show yes if if you are catholic
and you're you know gonna raise the kid
catholic uh then yeah the godparents
need to be catholic that's true
that's true it's just the way it is from
jamie i recently got engaged to a
wonderful man we will be getting married
in about six months or according to dr
fauci less than 15 days both of us are
active churchgoers and strong believers
in christ we recently started marriage
counseling with one of the ministers
from the church my fiance grew up in and
we've been reading the meaning of
marriage by tim keller together as well
do you have any advice for us as we move
through the rest of our engagement and
into young married life that might help
our marriage be successful and of strong
faith
my now fiance is the one who turned me
onto your show and we started dating so
as you might imagine we're both huge
fans that's great sounds like you found
a very excellent man with sound judgment
and good taste my fiance and i are
looking forward to any advice you might
have to offer yes i will give you the
advice
that actually ties in with the theme of
this show
do you have the right to commit sin
do we have the right to adultery do we
have the right to sort of pursue our own
tastes and appetites everywhere this is
advice that drew clavin gave me before i
got married i said you've been happily
married a long time what's your advice
he said here's my advice
don't sleep with other people
he used more colorful language i'm going
to clean that up because this is a
family show don't sleep with other
people
and you'll have a good you'll have a
good
wedding
or a good a good marriage rather i asked
jeremy for advice jeremy gives me good
advice too he said you know if you have
to go to bed angry
if you go to bed angry you're still
married in the morning
but if you if you make this thing i
won't go to bed angry and you just keep
some argument going on and on when
you're all tired and angry at your wits
and that's not going to be good either i
know these are both men who have been
married longer than i have
probably a bit more wisdom in that area
than i do but i think that's pretty
basic stuff yeah
do the right thing respect your you know
wives submit to your husbands husbands
love your wives i'm not sure which one
is more difficult at certain times
they're both difficult they're both
calls to do things that we are not
through our broken nature normally
inclined to do
uh and
you know
have have respect for your spouse
in in all things i mean you know in the
drew advice that means don't cheat on
your spouse and
in the in the sort of jeremy advice it
is recognized you're in this thing you
know you're in this thing
together and have have respect for them
don't just always try to win every
single point in every single argument i
mean
you know you'll you'll grow you'll grow
together ideally you'll grow together or
you'll grow apart so so make sure that
you you do that and uh yeah recognize
that this other person is now part of
you you know you're when when the good
lord says you're one flesh i mean that
is a very profound
image part of you so you wouldn't want
to
you wouldn't want to abuse some part of
yourself and
whether that's emotionally physically
obviously spiritually but
i guess in our culture we think that we
do have a right to abuse ourselves we do
think that we have a right to
sin and error
and but i don't think that you do so
don't do that either you know
the way that you treat
your spouse and the way that you treat
your own body are sort of the same thing
you should treat them both well from
jessie sweet nephew knowles
i have been in many different
conversations with my friends about the
draft and the future of warfare all of
them have told me that war will never be
fought in the same manner hand-to-hand
trench warfare etc this constitutes the
elimination of the draft
these normal people cannot operate
complicated equipment for instance
drones
what are your thoughts has warfare
changed forever with the advent of
drones and nukes to the point of
eliminating the draft if so should women
be included in a draft because physical
combat is no longer necessary congrats
on sweet baby june well
if there if you're saying if the premise
is there's not going to be any draft
anymore then i guess women should not
register because there's not going to be
any draft
but no i think that the military
is a very broad place there's lots of
different jobs in the military lots of
supportive roles and so i don't think
there's ever going to be a world in
which our wars are fought by 10 people i
think that there
the draft is still necessary because the
nation has to defend itself
and i don't think women should
register for the draft i think that's
wrong
i think it is you're right it does not
maximize individual autonomy it does
this particular view of mine it does not
eliminate the biological constrictions
of sex and nature
but that's just the way it is i think
that we need to stand up for what is
right and we need to embrace and enforce
such a vision i'm michael nolan's
michael show see you on monday
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin